foreign
[Music]
well there's been a bit of division news
dropping lately firstly Morton ryberg
product director and part of the very
small team that has been keeping the
division two moving forward has decided
after 17 years working with Ubisoft that
it's time to move on
Ollie is sit at the stages that he'll be
embarking on a New Journey in a
different industry
personally my interaction with Morton
has been fairly limited but I respect
what he's been able to do for the
franchise in his time working on The
Division II and that his colleagues have
always spoken very highly of them
so I wish him the best for the future
and to not be a stranger we as a
community seem to really hold on to divs
both past and present so I hope he
checks in from time to time
in other news the massive entertainment
Twitter account tweeted out that Julian
Garrity has been appointed executive
producer for the Tom Clancy's division
brand
Julian will oversee all games and
products including Tom Clancy's The
Division III led by Massive
entertainment who is actively building a
team for the game
this is 100 the most casual way that
they could have ever announced that the
division 3 is in the pipeline these days
it's more common for developers to
reveal the upcoming games in the biggest
way possible with loud flashy trailers
and numerous social media posts
attempting to attract as much attention
as possible
but apparently Ubisoft decided to forget
about all that hype stuff and just slip
it in there with a press release that
spoke more to Julian's change of role
than the division 3 itself
just seemed so blase like
congratulations to Julian and massive
and oh yeah we're gonna make another
game too
speaking of sequels my friends at
Logitech have sent me through the latest
in the Logitech Pro Series the pro Dex
super light 2 gaming mouse the Pro X tkl
Lightspeed gaming keyboard and the pro
X2 Lightspeed gaming headset I gotta be
honest I've been using the Pro X gear
for a long time now and I never had any
complaints so creating an ad for this
seemed like a bit of a struggle at first
however after using it for the last week
or so the pro X2 gear just seems like a
Natural Evolution think of it as trading
in for the newer lighter faster younger
model I mean who doesn't want that so I
can give you a younger brother
well I mean obviously some things age
like a fine wine or cheese although
maybe the smells what she's referring to
but when it comes to the pro X2 range it
does all the amazing things that the Pro
X range does but better the mouse has
gotten lighter and more precise the tkl
keyboard with the upgrade of logitech's
Lightspeed Wireless technology in up to
50 hours of battery life and anyone who
has been watching me for a while will
know how much of a stand I am for the
Pro X wireless headset I run these bad
boys on all of my systems well to my
surprise the pro X2 is a noticeable step
up with its new gpro graphene audio
drivers and it's even gotten a little
bit lighter the only downside is that I
now need to sweet talk and maybe show
some ankle to Logitech in order to
convince them into getting out my other
setups however it has suddenly become
apparent that I might have more success
if I sent my brother in my place
a big thank you to Logitech for
sponsoring the video
Julian joined massive entertainment and
was involved with the launch of the
original Tom Clancy's The Division in
2016. he would then move on to serve as
creative director on Tom Clancy's The
Division II
now he won't be moving over straight
away he'll be staying in his current
role of creative director of Star Wars
Outlaws until the title is shipped in
addition to Tom Clancy's The Division
three Julian will also oversee other
projects in the Tom Clancy's The
Division Universe including division
Resurgence and Tom Clancy's division
Heartland one of Julian's core focuses
going into the role will be to build a
team for Tom Clancy's The Division III
while making sure that the division 2
remains well supported which as we know
have only had a very small team for the
last few years
Julian goes on to say that there are
only a few games that I can genuinely
say blew me away the first time I saw
them and Tom Clancy's The Division is
one of them I was immediately hooked
like so many others who were a part of
our devoted player community it is a
privilege and honor to be able to
continue to build incredible and
Unforgettable experiences in this
amazing world with the most talented
teams around the world and I can't wait
for what's next
we may have over 40 million players but
the division is still in its early years
as a franchise there are so many more
incredible stories to tell places to
explore and people to protect
we don't know much about The Division
III at this stage as I said earlier
Julian is only just starting to build a
team beyond that we don't know any more
about this other than the fact that it
is a sequel it is likely to be at least
three or four years away
but the game itself isn't necessarily
the only thing that has hyped the
community it's the fact that Ubisoft
have officially stated that they are
continuing to not just support the game
but invest considerably more resources
back into its future
up until now the future of the division
franchise has been supported by upcoming
offshoot titles like Resurgence and
Heartland but this is the first time
anything has been said about continuing
the core game that a lot of us fell in
love with
people like myself who have been around
playing these games since early on
easily fall into a tunnel vision trap
where we're so passionate about the game
that perhaps we're not seeing the larger
picture
all it takes is a handful of people to
agree with what we're saying and then
suddenly we assume that's what the
majority of the community is also
thinking
we all wanted to see a division three
but none of us had any idea that this
was actually going to happen we were
just being hopeful
thankfully the higher-ups decided that a
further sequel could be justified
so what do I hope gets addressed in The
Division III well my wishlist could
probably be a much longer Standalone
video but I'll sum up a few bullet
points let's start with the obvious one
it's 2023 when this game comes out it
could be 2027. I'd like to see features
that are commonplace in more recent
games to be included in the division
most notably cross save and cross play
there is a very obvious reason why we
can't have this in the division too and
that comes from the foundations the game
was built on I'd love to see this
focused on very early on in the
development
atmosphere
I released a video about two years ago
titled why the division 2 is better than
the division
I knew what I was saying here and I knew
it would rile people up but they never
stopped me before the idea was to show
that the division 2 is a technically and
Visually Superior game to the original
as you would expect from a sequel
however the overwhelming majority agreed
that the atmosphere was a downscale not
graphically but the mood and feeling
I'm not ragging on the division 2
atmosphere and realistically it only
makes sense given the difference in
premise between each game one where
everything has just happened and you're
trying to survive and the other where
you're trying to rebuild
but this is beside the point not
everyone cares about the story however
everyone loves and misses that
post-apocalyptic feel
I don't think throwing us straight into
the snow again is the answer but I think
heavy consideration around atmosphere
and mood needs to be focused on
more meaningful and replayable game
modes
I understand that the last few game
modes have been released with limited
resource and that not every game mode
will be for everyone
but sometimes it feels like there's been
no feedback taken on
I'd love to see focus groups of A Sort
to discuss certain ideas around the game
modes for example to get player feedback
before investing developer's support
into pushing these through no I'm not
talking about getting a bunch of content
creators together I mean some actual
die-hard fans to see what they think I
know we have ETFs from time to time but
it always feels like it's too late by
then
content creators are for media events
they're not necessarily any good for
assisting in the future of a game
remember the tunnel vision thing I
talked about earlier there's clouds our
judgment
there have only been a handful of
content creators that I believe have
actually assisted in the development of
these games over the last seven to eight
years and most have moved on to other
things
last but certainly not least I'd like to
see them focus on the long game
the division is a live service game yet
with both the division 1 and the
division 2 is felt like an afterthought
past the first 12 months
I know this is actually more impacted by
the higher ups well outside of the
studio but don't look at the first few
months as an indication of the game's
future plan work fix innovate
I remember sitting in a room with the
old massive entertainment building after
being presented with Seasons as being
the constant trickle of content that the
division 2 will be getting after release
and then turning to the guy sitting next
to me actually that could be Marco's
Styles anyway I asked him is that it is
that the future content for the game now
this was before we knew anything about
Warlords of New York but the question
still stands outside of the one plan DLC
nothing else was ever on the program
obviously I personally don't mind season
they're basically created just for
players like me offering constant
updates to the story but I'll admit in
between each Target I don't really have
a lot to do
I'd like to see a more robust forecast
of what's coming over the months and
even years
it felt like after Warlords of New York
that everything just stopped until
recently of course
on that note bring back state of the
game don't do it weekly though do it
monthly or even quarterly make it
something that should be expected by the
community at certain times it reminds
everyone that the game is still being
fixed and worked on but can also be used
as a powerful hype tool if there is a
question of what could be featured on
the state of the game I have a ton of
ideas I don't just mean me doing goofy
skits or anything I mean actual things
the community would love to see
however I think I've traveled on long
enough in this video in summary the
division 3 has been announced it's very
early days but we are all super excited
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]